these images show Russia's Black Sea
Fleet headquarters in Crimea before and
after an attack on September
22nd the strike killed and injured
dozens including senior leaders of the
Navy according to Kev another attack on
Russia's principal Dry Dock in the city
of sevastopol in mid-september destroyed
a large Landing ship and heavily damaged
a submarine Ukraine has shown that it's
not only on the receiving end it can
attack attack Russia in return the
assaults are part of a Ukrainian
strategy to weaken military and
Logistics facilities on the occupied
Peninsula Ukraine wants to cut off
Crimea to make the peninsula untenable
here's why Ukraine has rammed up its
attacks on the
peninsula Crimea is crucial for Russia's
operations in Ukraine it's a supply hub
for Russian forces resisting Ukraine's
counter offensive which started in
summer 201 23 most important fighting is
happening in the southeast of Ukraine
Russian troops there are being supplied
um from cria so that's that's incredibly
important in particular because the
supply from the East is not as strong
Russia has also turned the peninsula
into a heavily militarized Zone since
the annexation in 2014 sevastopol is the
home of Russia's Black Sea Fleet where
some of the country's most sophisticated
warships are
stationed one way that the Black Sea
fleet has been used as a way to launch
cruise missiles that have struck
military civilian infrastructure targets
uh within Ukraine there are also several
important military air bases some of
which Ukraine has targeted since last
year to protect its assets Russia has
stationed air defense systems across the
peninsula in September Ukraine said
destroyed a sophisticated air defense
system known as the S400 the ukrainians
say that they sent in drones to attack
the S400 Radars they used two Neptune
missiles that were made by the
ukrainians and that they destroyed this
S400 system Ukraine has intensified
attacks on the occupied peninsula in
recent months as its ability to Target
Crimea improved Ukraine has gotten
cruise missiles from Britain and France
they've also developed their own weapons
that they've been able to use drones
torpedoes and the ukrainians have
figured out how to orchestrate very
complicated attacks Russia acknowledged
that two of its warships had been struck
in sevastopol and one service member was
missing after the attack on the Navy
headquarters but it didn't confirm any
damage to its air defense
systems as winter approaches Kev is
trying to neutralize the threats that
Russia's military Assets in Crimea posed
to Ukraine's critical
infrastructure Ukraine would like not
only to continue these attacks on Crimea
but also to ramp them up um a key part
of that is about getting supplies of
more long range missiles and longer
range missiles from the West the numbers
of cruise missiles from uh the UK and
from France are limited they're
producing their own Neptune uh cruise
missiles uh but it's not clear how many
of those they're able to produce in
September the White House told Ukraine
it would send a Advanced long range
surfac to a missiles according to us
officials the new missiles would add to
Ukraine's ability to launch longer range
strikes turning Crimea into an even more
dangerous place for Russian
[Music]
troops